what the [ __ ] you say vietnamese guy
yeah i said what the [ __ ] you looking at
you know walks over and then uh he gets
in my face so i get up
and then um his other homies who
came with him they stand behind uh the
friends that i'm with
my now the friends that i'm with have
their back turned to them oh [ __ ]
they're standing behind them
i see these fools pull out shanks and
then put it under their shirt like this
so this guy who's coming up to here to
me
is sitting here [ __ ] just talking
[ __ ] to my face
right today's tonight's the night dude
it's the night tonight's the [ __ ]
night in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast
uh we have a very very special and
regular guest we got edric back in the
house
over here today is my last day eating
unhealthy food actually last day out of
this week
because boy he's getting that six-pack
this year it's gonna happen
this fool is [ __ ] laughing at me
earlier he's heard it man
for 10 years verbatim sick i'm gonna get
a six-pack this year
it's gonna happen i feel it dude i feel
it i feel it's so good this year man
it's gonna happen man but you know the
six-pack exists
somewhere there you just have to have to
bring it to the surface
now dude all these [ __ ] ladies
they've been like damn david's funny
and he's fit nah the funny factor's
gonna go down
i'm gonna be uh who's who's a buff funny
guy um
well i mean i guess kevin hart's pretty
fit you know he's uh
he's funny yeah dave chappelle got
buffed for a second yeah
but he you see he didn't get like like
toned he just got
swole so he's still like big you know
i'm just gonna wear baggy shirts
but your boy about to have a six pack
dude makes the court you bigger dude
for my fans out there who don't know
what coach is scorcher's penis
this dude said hey whatever you want to
eat tonight after we're done with this
let me know because i got to the end of
the week
i'm eating whatever i can so what you
guys don't know if you if you're
watching this on the video
i have a knee sleeve on right now
because i thought that i was michael
jordan
and i found one basketball court in la
that was open
and i decided to do a layup and then i
exploded my knee
so god doesn't want me skinny trying to
do a layup and then my knee is exploding
but other than that i feel fantastic
dude it's going to happen i don't know
what's going to happen in my life when i
have a six-pack
i think it's going to change things dude
i mean the good thing is you're not
really going to need your legs
it's hard weight training though man it
is so [ __ ] i don't understand how people
weight train consistently all the time
and what kind of motivates them
i really got to get a bodybuilding in
here because i need to understand what
their mind state is about it you know
the thing is
i feel like there's different levels of
how much people enjoy food
you know some people can just like kind
of turn off their brain and just eat you
know chicken breasts and [ __ ]
broccoli and you know whatever every
single day serial killers yeah meal prep
and then they eat the same [ __ ] seven
days a week then there are others who
are like you know what i [ __ ] enjoy
food
i like things touching my tongue and me
feeling a sensation from it you know
there's some weird like i always tell
people there's this this chart of
fitness
and like enjoyableness right so
sometimes i think when people say first
of all okay let's i'll get a six-pack
i'll get like one of those the things
that you see you know when the light
changes
yeah you might see something just a
little bit of definition yeah just a
little definition i don't want six-pack
because when you when you look a certain
way there's a certain amount of things
you have to give up
there's like a good fine balance yeah
it's like who which which person do you
want to be do you want to be the person
with the six-pack that
has to have a very specific diet to try
to keep that year-round or do you want
to be the person that's just
you know relatively fit but still eats
generally what he wants and just
moderates
right right right you know yeah so i
don't know where i want to be i just
know that i just want a six-pack once
i want to see it change my life you've
never had a six-pack
never in my [ __ ] four pack never
never i don't know what an ab is i've
never had
i never had abs once just one surface is
one hard solid mass
never in my life have i ever had uh six
packs or like crazy pecs but what i did
have though i used to have
ripped [ __ ] quads because i used to
love
uh leg workouts okay it was like my [ __ ]
because i wanted to dunk
yeah so i used to just squat all the
[ __ ] time just squats
front squats lunges whatever you could
name like [ __ ] jump squats whatever
it wasn't very scientific but the only
thing that i made
super ripped were my [ __ ] quads like
i like i had i don't say i had
striations but
i had like quad separation and
everything i remember just looking at my
legs i was like what the [ __ ]
is this that's probably why you you
[ __ ] up your knees i know for sure i
didn't know what i was doing
but my legs have been relatively strong
back in the day but
ever since then i just stopped weight
training because it's just it's not fun
yeah yeah i don't like it doesn't make
it doesn't
i don't know it doesn't make me happy no
for sure i mean look man
like i said there's variations on like
how people look at food and what it
means to them
like even though i don't eat a lot i i
love
food you know i i love trying he doesn't
eat [ __ ]
but but context guys context i have acid
reflux so i
i can't i can't eat basically
to the point where i'm full my doctor
advised me when i first got diagnosed
with it like
just eat until you're satiated basically
so
i that's where i keep it at and it's
like you know it works out like
i i get to still eat the foods that i
like to eat but i just have to practice
don't [ __ ] eat moderation dude you
literally don't eat anything
and not only does he not eat anything if
you go this way doesn't give a [ __ ]
about the environment he uses 36 napkins
every time he [ __ ] eats
the most obnoxious thing i've ever seen
in my life i know but we went over this
there's
there's there's a method to the madness
there's no [ __ ]
method to the madness it's like you know
if you use one side of the napkin
you're not gonna wipe your mouth again
with the dirty side you gotta
flip it over and then you're done with
it but there's so much surface area to a
napkin besides that one spot i know i
know i know but it's just it's like an
ocd thing on top of it you know
like one side once i start to feel like
all right i'll give you an example so
like let's say i'm eating something
really greasy with my hands right
yeah you know if you wipe your hands
it's gonna get greasy again cause you're
gonna pick it up to eat it still
knowing that i mean like the the
sensible normal person would just
eat continue eating and then wipe out
but i got to keep wiping
because just that feeling that i have on
my fingers or my hands
is is like is disgusting to me you know
with the [ __ ] knife and fork man
don't even pick up [ __ ] dude i gotta
carry
do that [ __ ] like they do in those fancy
restaurants just eat a hamburger with a
knife and before
you eating a pizza with a knife and for
you it's [ __ ] ridiculous man
dude so one of our podcast reasons i was
telling him that we had our buddy pat
talk about uh
some of his old like fight stories when
he was younger dude y'all don't know a
[ __ ] fight story until you hear about
this fool's [ __ ] high school stories
and the crazy thing is right you know
when somebody sometimes tells you
stories like
you don't really get to hear the the
other side of what other people got to
experience as well
so we we had a guest on here before her
name is megan so
megan mitchell khalif and uh ed actually
all went to the same [ __ ] high school
and they all had the same [ __ ] story
and it's the most ridiculous thing i've
ever heard in my [ __ ] life
there's a story that this fool told i
mean you got to tell the story it's
[ __ ] nuts just
just because of how violent this school
is like it's it's unreal how
and i i was told by bart actually at
that time
so bart went to his parents moved him
to the oc area i believe for him to go
to school there
but lo and behold they didn't know when
they assumed that it was like a really
nice area yeah
during that time it was ridden with a
bunch of gangs yeah so i
i mean i think i i know what uh junior
high bart went to for a little bit
yeah um that's still not orange county
though
it's still borderline la county um
but yeah at that time at that school
um well i mean [ __ ] man just around the
whole area you know like i mean
it was the 90s like gang culture was so
popular you know like
gang culture is kind of like what
what would you even compare to right now
like talk
yeah being an influencer you know like
that gang
gangsters were the influencers of that
time yeah so
everybody kind of looked to like gangs
and gangster music
and kind of you know uh were influenced
by that so
you know at that time um there was
i would say like maybe about
three or four classes yeah and what i
mean by classes is like let's say if
you're in seventh grade like eighth
grade ninth grade tenth grade like there
was
maybe about four classes where there
were just
a bad group of of people yeah
um and it kind of trickled down from
like the older people too
um so you know it was uh
it wasn't exactly the most friendliest
of environments for sure
um and then it was like
if you're on the wrong end of that life
could be pretty miserable for you
you know on a daily basis uh so
it was just like a constant thing of
like you have to
one not be a punk like if if somebody is
is kind of trying to check you or like
you know trying to do something
i mean the biggest thing like the most
common thing was like
it was called taxing i don't know if you
guys had that uh
that term uh up in up in sacramento
would you just steal people's [ __ ]
lunch money and [ __ ]
well yeah basically that's that's what
people would do they would tax people
right yeah terrible people yeah yeah and
then so like you know
if they thought you were punk you get
taxed right
and like most of the time the people who
are getting taxed
were kind of too scared or like too soft
to do anything
but then if you weren't
kind of in that group of the ones
getting taxed you were that
the taxer not the taxi yeah
you're the irs pretty much you know
um within that
group of people there was always kind of
like testing you know what i mean
like sizing each other up and and then
like
rival schools too uh people from
different schools
like it would be kind of like a school
thing where it's like
nah we could bomb on your school or you
know they could bomb on and then it
becomes a thing like all of a sudden
there's beef now right
so it was just i don't know man like the
dynamic of like
that whole situation was was just really
weird
and well that checking thing was so was
so interesting it's like
i remember just uh
just kind of like someone like the older
youngs right they wouldn't they would
have this habit of looking at people who
would just walk by
and immediately no matter who it [ __ ]
is yeah they would just size them up
like if we if we were to throw down
right now can i [ __ ] this person up yeah
and it could just be some regular dude
just walking
yeah for sure for sure that that's what
it was man i mean it that
you know it would it's called dogging
right like you would dog people to see
like all right what are they about you
know
um and then you bring kind of like the
gangs into it
and then it's like not just dogging now
you're claiming [ __ ]
right like you're going you're trying to
bang on people pretty much
yeah so you know there were like very
like extreme uh variations of like how
seriously people took it some people
were just trying to pose
some people were like all about it you
know and
it's like it's kind of funny because you
know generally that area might have been
a suburban community
but when you see kind of like the
profile of these people who are
gravitating towards that type of
lifestyle right and behavior a lot of
them came from
you know not the best homes yeah yeah
yeah like
you know there was family trouble maybe
it's a single parent home
uh financial struggles uh their parents
just don't give a [ __ ] about the kid
right whatever the case may be there was
some sense of like brokenness within
like the family unit
yeah and then you could see like those
are the type who all kind of gravitated
towards each other
yeah right and then it became like a
group um so with that context
the the story that you're referencing
there's like 30 of them too by the way
i mean there's there's a whole lot to
really get into about that but the story
in particular that you're referencing
so what had happened was um uh
i got into a fight with somebody and
then um
you know [ __ ] went down and then uh
this one dude who wasn't exactly
the biggest of guys either um he just
started talking [ __ ]
started kind of like popping off like oh
you know that that [ __ ] was like weak
like y'all [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
everyone just kind of stopped like who
the [ __ ] is this dude nobody knew who
the [ __ ] this dude
was right and then everybody's just kind
of asking each other like you know who
this dude is right
so he was in your guys class though no
he wasn't he wasn't he was uh
two years older than us i think two or
three years older than us okay yeah
so we're just kind of like who the [ __ ]
is this dude right but uh one of my
homies in particular
really got it got into it with him and i
think it's because
my homies also kind of on the shorter
side and he was also on the shorter side
so maybe he was looking for like
you know who we thought might be the
easiest target yeah
and then so they got into it um and
i didn't really think anything about it
beyond that right
but then the next week this dude was
just saying talking [ __ ] out of it was
just talking [ __ ] basically just talking
[ __ ] he was just going around i think he
was just trying to like
flex you know he was because because i
guess
well i mean i found out after the fact
but he was new to the school
and and he was coming from a different
school
and so he kind of probably had the
mentality like
a lot of the dudes here and [ __ ] you
know
because like where he's from is a lot
yeah yeah and then he's gonna let us
know
like who he is and and where he's from
that type of [ __ ] you know yeah
but the thing is is like he thought he
was in prison he was like we're not
gonna win
i gotta find the biggest [ __ ]
exactly and take their lunch
it was highly unnecessary you know so
obviously like all of me and my friends
take take offense to it immediately like
who the [ __ ] is this dude right like
this dude is popping off
and then it's like you know you're
willing to even give him the benefit
of the doubt if it's like somebody
else's man like hey
yeah yeah you need to check your man
right now you know but
nobody knew who the [ __ ] he was so like
that that made it even more
of kind of like a question mark uh like
a mystery like who's this cat
and then we found out you know we talked
to someone like you know the the
the guys in the in his class and they're
like oh yeah you know
he just came over from this school so
it's like
who the [ __ ] does he think he is you
know coming over here like saying [ __ ]
like that
and then so i didn't really think much
of it it just irritated me but then it
was more like if this dude pops off
again then he's getting jumped pretty
much
his podcast is brought to you by me
undies have you ever looked at a pair of
your underwear and wondered why you
chose to have this shred of sandpaper
cover your delicates you're asking
yourself
these questions because you don't own a
wonderful pair of me
undies the crap you have on now is
hideous and you should be ashamed of
yourself
well no more because you're better than
that my friends you are better than that
listen bottom line when it comes to your
underwear it has to be comfortable i
don't care
and i love me undies they look dope but
best of all
it feels amazing it's one of the only
few boxers that i own
that feels softer and softer every time
i wash it
and you don't realize how dope it is to
have a comfortable pair of boxers until
you find the right one and i found it so
i usually sleep butt naked but these are
kind of so comfortable
i feel butt naked without being but
naked so to get
15 off your first order free shipping a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
go to me undies dot com slash brain
once again that's me undies dot com
slash
brain you know but then the next day
um yeah uh the guy
the homie i'm talking about that that
got into it with that dude all right so
sort of
for the sake of uh making it easier to
understand i give fictitious names okay
you know
my homie we'll call him um james
okay and then this dude we'll call him
uh
nick james and nick okay um
so you know my homie james
got into it with this dude nick the next
day again
and uh i i saw this [ __ ] happen
so i went over to to my homie james
immediately
and then i was i just kind of you know
tried to calm him down
yeah i was like hey just just chill like
we'll get him
you know wait what did he do so the dude
threw a book
nick threw a book at james that's right
that's right yeah yeah he threw a book
at him and he was popping off
you know i don't know what led to that
uh
all i know is up to that point and then
so i was trying to tell james like it
just calmed down you know like
we'll get him right but he didn't
respond to me
i've never seen a look of like
fury in his eyes before like that this
dude was like i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
this dude
from like just looking at him i was like
oh [ __ ] yeah you know this shit's going
down right
so that was like in between the periods
and then so that dude nick he went off
he went into class right
and then so i was like all right you
know what as soon as this
this period's over like like james
he he's he's on one right now he's not
gonna wait you know
so i was just like kind of amped up and
i was just waiting waiting i was like
come on come on come on like
waiting for the class to end as soon as
like the bell hit i just [ __ ] threw
my backpack ran into the hallway
and i'm looking for these dudes i'm like
all right where they at where they at
and then like everybody starts coming
out of their classes in the hallway
and then like moses part in the red sea
man
the the crowd just starts splitting open
like this
and then it's uh my homie uh james
and then two other homies uh one of
which was he was like [ __ ] six feet
you know
hundred ninety minutes in eighth grade
it's a big [ __ ] dude right
they're rushing this dude nick um
and like there was like no time to even
really react to what was happening
you just saw the crowd starting to split
open and then these dudes were rushing
him
and i was like how the [ __ ] did they
even like coordinate this they could
sense anger
yeah i guess so man um and then
yeah basically uh the big dude like he
like shoved him into the locker they
were basically like
rushing him and the dude was like trying
to back up you know
the big dude shoved into the locker and
then like his [ __ ] head bounced off
of it and these are metal lockers mind
you right
yeah and when a dude that big is pushing
a guy that size into it
like he's hitting it with force yeah so
he [ __ ] bounces off of it and then
when his head comes back forward he
[ __ ]
throws a punch at him hits it again
and then he [ __ ] falls and then he
just starts getting stomped out
you know and um my homie uh
james too like even though he's a small
dude
he was built like [ __ ] derek fisher
like he's a small dude but he's [ __ ]
ripped yeah
like even at that age he was six pack
like [ __ ] veins in his arms right
yeah he didn't even work out he's just
naturally blessed like that you know
um athletic guy too but yeah and so like
he's he's [ __ ] strong like you can't
underestimate like you might think oh
cause he's short he's he might be not
dude's [ __ ] strong so his this dude
is wearing like [ __ ] tims
you know and and he's like stomping out
on this dude um and
long story short man again it became
pretty chaotic i mean they
they [ __ ] that dude up i didn't even
really have a chance to jump in
because i was just like it was happening
so
so quickly all at once and then like
faculty started coming out and then like
you know they started tackling everybody
trying to stop it
and then by by the end of it the dude
was just
man he was just [ __ ] bleeding
everywhere you know he was just dripping
blood from his face i'm sure he had like
some broken rib like he got
[ __ ] up that's [ __ ] nuts he went
all right when he was on all fours
right the homie james [ __ ] kicked him
like full force up like this into his
gut
so imagine being on on all fours you
know you're like trying to catch your
breath because you you got
punched and kicked or whatever and then
somebody's kicking you full
and then it makes him lifts off the
ground right oh so i was like that's
what i'm saying i'm pretty sure he had
broken ribs
and you know had some like internal
damage but
he got pretty [ __ ] up well what the
what the [ __ ] was he thinking
what did he think was going to happen it
was just him
i thought like when he did that he
probably had like a group of people with
him no no no so but here's the thing
here's the thing is that
you know we obviously um kind of
checked like who we knew you know what i
mean like if
it's really don't know anybody yeah and
the thing is like where he was from the
school he was from like
dude we our homies were from there you
know what i mean like
um so nobody knew who the [ __ ] this dude
was
so we're like i [ __ ] this footage
yeah yeah yeah who the [ __ ] this guy
think he is that's hella random
yeah so you know he got he got he got
his
and then um afterwards
like when it kind of had calmed down i
was like you know what man there's no
point even me jumping in
like this dude was pretty [ __ ] up but
then
some of my other homies decided to
still jump in at that point and and give
him a last few kicks
just for good measure to let him know
like dude at that point it was that was
not super necessary that was super
unnecessary you know
um and then uh that that kind of started
a whole wave of like everybody getting
kicked out
of the school yeah and like the
administration was looking for any
excuse to get rid of us anyway
yeah and that gave him the perfect
reason right
so everybody got kicked out they got
sent to different schools because they
didn't want them to be together
um and that that ultimately for me was
like a really big turning point because
like
you know here were the guys that i was
hanging out with all the time
and then most of them are gone now and
i'm i'm pretty much
on the verge of getting kicked out too
so they they created like
some some stupid policy just just for
like a handful of us
what they would consider like the bad
seeds that are left
basically what it said was if we do
anything wrong
from now until we graduate we're kicked
out oh [ __ ] detention you're kicked out
you get kicked out of class you're
kicked out a teacher complains about you
you're kicked out so it's pretty much
like yeah
there's no at that point i'm like 13 14
years old yeah there's
no way i'm going yeah you know so i
even at that point i told my parents
like hey listen you know i'm on this
on what they call the behavior contract
it's like i'm on this thing
there's no way there's no [ __ ] way so
i might as well just uh
save myself to trouble and just bounce
now yeah and my parents are like
there's no [ __ ] way we're gonna we're
gonna sign off on you going because all
the other schools were
worse you know so um
they're just like if you get kicked out
you get kicked out
you're not going out like on your own
decision
you know and like i said dude that
ultimately was kind of like
my turning point my saving grace i mean
i didn't get better immediately you know
there was kind of like
a transitional process and uh the crazy
[ __ ] is man i went from being
like one of the most hated students
probably by faculty
on on at school by the time i was
graduating like one of the most loved
because everybody saw like where
i was and like kind of the transition i
was trying to make you know
yeah and so they gave me a lot of leeway
with [ __ ] bro
a lot of leeway um i won't say certain
things in terms of leeway that i was
given because i don't want to get
certain faculty in trouble but yeah when
i say i was given a lot of leeway
i was able to get away with stuff that
you normally would not be able to
probably just like
he's better than what he was yeah
exactly they started trying to help me
out you know
and like my uh my counselor
she was the one who really had my back
like
there were so many counselors before her
who basically were like super dismissive
and like
talk down to me and basically say you
know that's in not so many words that
i'm a piece of [ __ ] you know
yeah um but this one counselor when she
took over our class
like for some reason man she she just
would not she made it a point with to
not give up
you know she's like no matter what
you're gonna graduate
and i'm gonna do everything in my power
to make sure that happens
so i've always been super thankful to
her and and
i've expressed that to her um like you
know i still talk with her once in a
while just to like
yeah she's she's in another state now
but just to
you know uh show her my gratitude let
her know like it's something that i
think about because
it's so weird because like i remember
high school like high school i always
hung out with like the
the the nicer kids you know but i think
i felt all the people that were
bad influences in my life they were well
they didn't last in school
so yeah after school i would go and hang
out with them
yeah and it was so weird just kind of
wanting to be around that and like it
made me feel
i don't know maybe feel i don't want to
say cool but made me feel very
comfortable like
whatever went on high school i could
give a [ __ ] less so it's like well these
guys have my back
you know and they're a lot older yeah
and i was just like that goofy funny kid
that wasn't
outside i was just like oh cool this is
fun yeah but just having that
that small little window of what happens
here it's just like
it's odd like i can't even remember what
it's like to be like that sometimes
sometimes when i go back to sacramento
and i go back to like certain spots i
used to kick it at
and it's just a little ghetto and i'm
like oh look at these [ __ ] trash
human beings
like that's the spot i used to kick it
at yeah and i'm like all these heathens
dude yeah i mean but you know back then
like that's just what it was it's like
dude you know when you're 12 13 years
old you're not thinking about like
uh what am i gonna be uh when i'm you
know an adult a responsible mature adult
like you have very immature thoughts and
and you're thinking about [ __ ] that's
cool and you want to be kind of
of a certain crowd right be part of a
certain crowd
so like for me it wasn't even like
making an attempt to like be around
those type of people
yeah it's just my background of where i
was coming from
uh like all right here's here's some
context too to that situation is like
before i i went to that school which was
in like predominantly asian area
i was living in lakewood right so i was
living in lakewood in the borderline of
like
hg and long beach okay so it was pretty
much hispanics and blacks
right that was the community so at my
school that i was at
there were maybe like i don't know five
other asian kids six other asian kids
you know what i mean
so when i got there i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on like where are
all these asian people coming from
yeah and like i had to get acclimated to
that too because
they were all coming from like schools
within that area
so they had known each other on some
level you know
whereas for me i'm a complete outsider
yeah i'm coming in i'm like
dude i don't know what the [ __ ] this
community is about i don't know who the
[ __ ] these
these people are like everything was
really foreign to me
and then so like you start to get
acclimated to that and then
you know you start kind of uh banding
together with certain types of people
and that's what i'm talking about yeah
you know depending on like what type of
background you were coming from
you just kind of naturally gravitate
towards that and then those were the
people
who also happen to have a lot of anger i
also feel like korean people do they
just
they they kind of enjoy that type of
culture a lot
like specifically kind of the the
bullying the younger crowd type of thing
and kind of the hierarchy the hierarchy
is very weird like in korean culture
specifically like
dude so when i when i came to l.a i
don't know if you know who this guy is
i'm not going to say anything he scares
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me
but this guy so when i came to l.a
there was this uh show that i did and
there was a show
specifically with a a korean
star right and he was i'm not gonna say
his name but he was a rapper
right right uh i hosted this show and
this korean rapper i you know i grew up
listening to him and i was like oh this
is really cool dude
nobody [ __ ] told me this guy's like
bipolar like he's [ __ ] nuts
yeah yeah he's a [ __ ] nut yeah
nut bag right yeah and so uh he meets me
i make a couple of jokes he thinks i'm
really funny and he's like yo you should
come kick it with us right i was like yo
this is dope you know
you know this dude's asking me to come
out i'm definitely gonna come kick it
with him
and so there is one of my homegirls knew
who he was too and so she kind of
introduced me to him in the first place
that's how i you know made the jokes or
whatever
and he goes yo come to this spot and uh
and and so inside this apartment
building
there is a secret uh there's a there's
one place that's not even an actual
apartment
it's a bar but it's like a secret thing
that
nobody [ __ ] knows about you're only
allowed in there they let you in there
right right right i didn't know about i
was like oh this is some [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] yeah
so i walk in right and i [ __ ] [ __ ]
you not there's this
you know i you know what [ __ ] what's
his name odd job the the the
who's the bald korean dude in like that
double 07. oh no in austin powers the
bald korean dude
bald korean dude and austin powers and
austin austin powers are the one that
[ __ ] he has like the hat that he
throws and it
it sliced off the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so he looks like him yeah right and
so i walk into this room and you see
this bar
and it's it's a cityscape you can kind
of see the dtla down this way
and when you walk in it's it's dimly lit
and there's these rgb lights going on
this dude behind the bar and yeah
yeah yolked ass korean dude yeah not
that big yeah
oh no he's really big i'm sorry not that
big but he's really big and i just walk
in and this guy goes i [ __ ] you not he
goes
tiny yeah and i'm like excuse me
all right there's the first i go excuse
me he goes tiny
and i'm like tiny what he goes [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ] name
i'm not even [ __ ] kidding you i
almost [ __ ] my [ __ ] pants yeah yeah
and it's
yolk yeah i'm like why they call them
tiny why they call me tiny yeah
this is full he goes you know what they
call me tidy i'm like nah he goes
because i'm not tiny
and i i don't know at this point if he's
making a joke or not
yeah because he doesn't smile this is a
true [ __ ] i don't think i ever told
the story on the spot yes
he doesn't smile so i never know when
he's [ __ ] telling a joke and he's
over here just threatening me
and i'm looking at my homework like who
the [ __ ] is this guy
oh he's sweet i was like yeah to you
because you're his [ __ ] friend
this feels like mean he's like
mistreating me yeah
i'm sitting there and he offers me a
drink it's like a jamison or some [ __ ]
i drink it whatever right so we go off
into this corner
so there's the bar here and there's a
back area where everybody chills
and we're sitting there and he starts
telling these stories
right and so what i later found out
about that dude he's kind of like
i heard he was like really affiliated
back in the day then he went from that
to being like a like honestly like a
loan shark
so that's why he's so [ __ ] scary yeah
yeah first of all i don't even know why
he was he could just say his his
name tiny and i'm supposed to know what
the [ __ ] he's saying there's no
there is no context so why are you mad
at me
yeah so i'm sitting here and i'm [ __ ]
freaked the [ __ ] out yeah so i'm sitting
here i'm just like cool whatever i get
to you know kick it with this
this legendary rapper that i look up to
yeah so this is where i found out that
he's a little bipolar and weird
i sat there by the way and i thought it
was going to be just us chopping it up
and then maybe i was going to leave
after an hour
he wouldn't let me leave because he
wanted to tell me his whole life story i
was there
i [ __ ] [ __ ] you not i was there for
six hours
oh my god cause he wouldn't let me leave
he wouldn't let me leave and mr tiny
wouldn't let me leave
right so i'm sitting here and tiny
throughout the whole night yeah
he's saying some really obscure [ __ ]
like scary [ __ ] but
because i don't think he knows that he's
not a [ __ ] funny person nobody knows
when he's joking right right so like he
would say some [ __ ] like this right like
this is why
i'm quoting him by the way and he's
talking about the show that's about to
happen the next day
yeah and he goes yo man wouldn't this
[ __ ] be [ __ ] funny if i just scared
the whole [ __ ] crowd and i just
bought up my [ __ ] piece and he has a
gun on him he whips it out yeah
i'm sitting here like the [ __ ] is going
on and he goes
if i just started capping people out in
the crowd and i'm
dead [ __ ] silent yeah right and he
goes that's not funny
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
i just start laughing but how the [ __ ]
am i supposed to know he's making jokes
the whole night it was uncomfortable for
six [ __ ] hours he's making these
things that nobody knows is a [ __ ]
joke
i think he's like a sociopath so
i'm sitting there for six [ __ ] and i'm
on the verge of [ __ ] falling asleep i
was there till 4am oh my god
4am and they just kept giving me drinks
over and over and over and he was
telling me about his life how he grew up
and
he how he actually grew up in the states
all this gang affiliation
and this dude's over here talking about
shooting people in the crowd i was
scared shitless
so after they finally let me leave and
i'm telling you i tried to leave and
they
literally physically wouldn't let me
leave and so the sexual ass back down
yeah
and so the next day uh we did the show
the show
first of all the show was a disaster
because the artist that came there
he came uh super [ __ ] late he was
drunk out of his mind yeah
and uh when he went up on stage and he
performed he
forgot all the [ __ ] lyrics because he
was out of his [ __ ] mind
forgot the lyrics and then on top of
that he starts talking
on when he's on the stage yeah he starts
talking about how he was jacking off in
the room and by you this is this is a
charity show oh no
he gets on the stage and he talks about
how he was jacking off in the bathroom
and then his dead grandmother came into
the bathroom to scold him while he was
while he was [ __ ]
uh whacking one off this is a [ __ ]
charity concert dude for a good cause
yeah so after the show was over right
and this show was such a [ __ ]
disaster because of that stuff i was
supposed to do
um just host the show and just do like a
quick maybe 30 seconds
of talking in between yeah to introduce
the next one right right
they [ __ ] up that show so bad yeah i
essentially had to do
20 minutes to stand up [ __ ] six times
over so i did like a two
you remember this i remember this yeah
you remember i had to do that and i was
[ __ ] livid yeah so this little tiny
after the show was over he goes yes amen
you were really [ __ ] funny and i was
like hey
after this you're not gonna go to the
after party you're gonna come kick it
with us
like i have a choice right like he
wasn't even giving me an option right
i was like oh yeah yo thanks tanya i
appreciate it man yes i'll see y'all
there he goes
how the [ __ ] you gonna be there if you
don't give me your [ __ ] number yeah
i'm like oh [ __ ] my bad dog
and you know this is threatening me man
and so i'm like all right cool
and so i gave him my number yeah and i'm
about to walk away he goes where the
[ __ ] are you going yeah
i'm like i don't know you said you're
gonna see me later you're gonna hit me
up yeah he goes no we're kicking it in
the back right now
i'm back there and then uh i'm back
there right it's that korean rapper and
the rosco molly uh-huh he's back there
you remember roscoe molly
so rosco molly's back there yeah and i'm
sitting there and they're just having a
conversation
none of them acknowledge me yeah and i'm
standing there yeah
and once again i try to leave he doesn't
let me
leave so i'm in the back for an hour
watching them just talk and smoke and
drink yeah and i'm standing there like a
statue
yeah he's just part of the decoration
i think he just has that korean like
like tongsen like punking mentality yeah
yeah
so you from what i heard what other
people told me he goes yo tiny likes you
a lot
and i'm like i couldn't [ __ ] tell
this was just [ __ ]
he's like treating me like a little
[ __ ] the whole time yeah yeah but that
[ __ ] was the most uncomfortable
situation i've ever been and this is me
as an adult right right
one i'm not from la i don't know anybody
yeah i don't know who's affiliated i
don't know what neighborhoods i'm in i
don't know what parts are dangerous i
don't know what parts are safe
so this whole time my [ __ ] is
sweating this guy just
would kept punking me but it was weird
like going in the back i see roscoe and
molly back there and they're just
chopping it up yeah and i'm trying to
leave and he's like where are you going
i'm like no i'm just chilling and i
stood there with my hands crossed
and then lo that's when i found out that
he's kind of like a loan shark and he
just does [ __ ] so i'm like okay well i'm
i'm gonna
once you flash a gun at me i'm i'm gonna
stab you yeah
i mean i think i think i'm gonna just
chill
and i'm gonna wait till he allows me to
leave yo after that [ __ ] i blocked his
number and i finally disappeared
i disappeared off the face of the
[ __ ] earth he kept on wanting to hang
out
but i don't i didn't know what that
entailed this [ __ ] was so [ __ ] scary
[ __ ] that guy
i love you don't hit me don't find me no
but i mean yeah a lot of that a lot of
that was the case though back in the day
was like
so much of a demanding respect you know
and it's like if you don't know who i
am i'm gonna make sure you know real
quick you get familiar with who i am
right and a lot of that would be kind of
like
you know bravado and like being like
talking and
acting tough right and but the thing is
it's like
you don't you also don't want to test it
either right absolutely yeah
it's like all right man if if that's the
the persona that you're presenting to me
i'll believe it you know you don't gotta
go over the top for me
to to to like make your case yeah i
believe you i'm 100
and first of all the the girl after
after the homegirl who introduced me to
him right
i stopped talking to her after this she
don't even know why it's because you
left me
yeah with a bunch of people who are
flashing their [ __ ] gun at me oh she
bounced she bounced
she bounced at 1am oh man so i was
pissed i was like she goes i'm sleepy
and she got up and she just [ __ ] left
i was so [ __ ] mad and i was just
there yeah
not that i could imagine how
uncomfortable
she didn't she didn't even ask if i
wanted to go yeah she goes i'm really
sleepy guys i'll see you all tomorrow
and then i'm like you couldn't have
taken me with you [ __ ]
the funniest [ __ ] was to when they said
that i assumed that i was gonna leave
two
and this little tiny interjects he goes
yeah me the boys are just gonna kick in
and drink and he looked at me
and i'm like i'm the boys i'm not one of
the boys
that's a visitor that's what i knew i
was supposed to be here all night yeah
and it was weird listening to that
dude's life story he was talking about
crazy [ __ ] man just like talking ab when
he
when he said that he wanted to go in the
crowd and just start blasting off on
people i mean this guy's a [ __ ] nut
job
and how the [ __ ] is anybody supposed to
know that's a joke right right that's
not a joke
that's a threat that's a terrorist yeah
and he got mad at me because i didn't
laugh
yeah so i was like no you were the worst
stand-up comic i've ever met in my life
for sure they're like they're they're
you know you you definitely meet those
personality types who are
you know a little bit more extreme with
that [ __ ] i mean bro
there's man there's been a lot of crazy
[ __ ] happen
you know uh especially like during that
whole 90s period early 2000s period with
you know people just like hot tempered
they got strapped out of it
yeah dude bro they it [ __ ] pops off
in a hurry right like there was this one
time
um at a at a [ __ ] uh uh
pool hall right everybody used to go to
pool halls back then you know of course
yeah
and that's just where everybody kicked
it yep and then there was a spot
where a lot of people um
a lot of basically bangers used to come
out and kick it but then because of that
[ __ ] would tend to pop off there a
little bit more frequently than
a normal pool hole right because when
you got
like people who aren't affiliated or
don't know each other
coming like outsiders coming in and and
maybe they're from another set
i mean [ __ ] will pop off quickly right
so you know there
there were times when like things would
get crazy and like yeah this one time
[ __ ] popped off dude went to his [ __ ]
uh car pulled out a shotgun cocked that
[ __ ]
boom it hit you know sprayed it on the
ground [ __ ] the the
the um the pellet space what do you call
it pellets or what would you call it
it's like
i don't know the buckshot shrapnels or
whatever yeah yeah so it hit the [ __ ]
thing
got lodged in the dude's head you know i
was like
that's how quickly would escalate you
know like people weren't [ __ ] around
man like
and and like once people started getting
so here was the biggest
kind of um like double whammy uh was
people started getting strapped and then
tweaking became
oh [ __ ] the tweaking epidemic you know
and so like
people were [ __ ] like just twacked
out of their mind
and and they're running around strapped
so they're not even
they haven't even slept in like twenty
four forty eight hours
man and you know they're not thinking
straight and so a lot of crazy [ __ ]
would happen man
that respect thing is something that was
uh that was always consistently tested
when i went to a house party once
uh once again i just keep getting
invited to [ __ ] that i don't want to
[ __ ] go to
i had a real problem with saying no
you know well it's it's the type of
people you don't want to say no to
exactly because they're also the funny
thing and i was talking about uh
i was talking about those with bart
recently it was like it was a lose-lose
situation like for somebody like me
as a younger person yeah it's like okay
if i say no
these older hyungs are gonna beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of me or
i would have to go out and they would
for i would have to be forced to fight
somebody else so i might as well just do
what they say and then keep it
keep it all cool right because they only
you know it was
partially my fault because i did like
being around them but
what i remember when i went to this one
house party and this dude
and this is like when air force ones
were [ __ ] popping right so he had
these
brand new air force ones and they were
inside this house party house was
[ __ ] dirty and filthy by the way
and dudes were smoking or whatever guy
uh spits
and then he spits on this dude's shoe
looks like the guy he goes i'll [ __ ] my
bed and he just turns around
this dude [ __ ] gets up i had no idea
who this guy is
yeah guy gets up smallest little [ __ ]
vietnamese dude you have ever seen
[ __ ] cute as [ __ ]
looks like he looks like a little
[ __ ] troll doll right with [ __ ]
bangs and he gets up
and he goes clean my [ __ ] shoe yeah
and he goes like what he's like [ __ ] you
yeah with the n-word yeah
all right i'm like i'm watching this i'm
sitting i'm sitting on a couch
i'm sitting on a couch by the way right
yeah and when he gets up
he gets up and i'm talking about like
seven or eight dudes get up at the same
time so he was rolling deep
right no [ __ ] clue all of them
strapped
right and he goes like [ __ ] you n-word
right
he looks at him he goes nah you gonna
clean my [ __ ] shoe lifts his shirt up
yeah
everybody is strapped up yeah that dude
got on his [ __ ] knees had a napkin
and he wiped this [ __ ] shoe off and
he told him to get the [ __ ] out
yeah that [ __ ] scared the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of me man he made a grown-ass dude
that's twice his size yeah this little
five foot two asian dude
wipe his shoe with the napkin
apologizing but you know that's
that's that's what it is though man it's
like dude
you have to really weigh out the pros
and cons in that situation
because it's like all right what do you
do yeah if these dudes are strapped are
you gonna really lose your life over
you not being able to swallow your pride
for i mean yeah it's it's [ __ ]
uh you know emasculating and
embarrassing for sure but
at the end of the day you're like yeah
that's just gonna be forgotten
after that night dude i was sitting on
the couch i was about to tug on his
jeans like
dude just [ __ ] away like i don't want
to die dude you know
look man there there's there's been an
instance too where um
my homie uh basically like a girl he was
dating uh her older brother
was he he was a banger right yeah he was
he was a pretty rough dude
and uh they went out drinking together
and um
i think he brought out one of his other
homies and then they were
at a bar i think in k-town drinking
and then um [ __ ] kind of popped off
you know uh with with some somebody else
that was there
and then um this i mean i'll tell you
after the podcast who it was that
it popped off but yeah so his hit the
the
the girl's older brother kind of got
into it i think with somebody else
and then all of a sudden dude gets up
and then like 10 other dudes get up and
then they all put their hands under
their shirt
and then the dude is like oh [ __ ]
yeah he wasn't he he didn't have a strap
on him yeah but even if he did
wouldn't matter you got 10 dudes
surrounding you yeah he didn't know that
everybody sitting around was all part of
the same group
right same [ __ ] i mean this dudes and
actually like from what i hear
i've never met the dude but he's
apparently you know had a like
rough past and is with like for reals
not not just like a
posing but even in that situation
you got you got it you got to take it
yeah it's like
all right yeah i if i try to do
something
i'm done yeah you know not only am i
done my little sister
you know my friend i've been put in a
similar situation before
too where i was chilling with some home
so
this is what i'm like 17 18. yeah by
then you know i'm just
my focus is i'm trying to get to college
yeah you know i'm just trying to like
go down a straight path not not get into
any trouble i'm hanging out
and um a group of maybe like 15 dudes
walk uh walk into where we're hanging
out at it's it's outdoor area outdoor
seating right
and there's there's like two islands
right so i'm sitting on one side and
then this other group of guys
come in and then they sit on the other
side pretty a good amount of distance
between us
and then i just kind of look at them and
then i'm like ah you know these dudes
kind of look like you know they're up to
no good yeah but
it doesn't really matter right so i
don't really think anything of it
and then maybe about like 15 minutes
later like me and my homies are just
sitting and talking
um and and mind you most of these guys
that i'm with
are not never were really involved in
that type of stuff
they're good guys you know one other
homie
was you know yeah but
two girls walk by walk by our table
they're pretty cute
they walk by this way and then and then
stop
like little bit past our table and then
start walking back
i was like all right that's kind of
weird i thought they were like going
somewhere you know maybe to the bathroom
or to a store or whatever
and then they're cute so i say what's up
right
i just say what's up and then they look
and they smile at me so i'm like alright
cool
and then i just go back to talking with
my homies
uh maybe not a minute later i start to
see
like five dudes starting to walk over to
our area yeah
and then i it catches my i see it from
the corner of my eye so i i turn my head
and i look
and then they're walking over and
they're dogging me
and i get [ __ ] irritated you know
like
i don't think i i still had that
maturity to check my
my uh emotions yeah it's not like what
the [ __ ] you looking at man
yeah i said that to him right what the
[ __ ] you say
vietnamese guy yeah i said what the [ __ ]
you looking at you know
walks over and then uh he gets in my
face so i get up
and then um his other homies who
came with him they stand behind
the friends that i'm with my now the
friends that i'm with have their back
turned to them
oh [ __ ] they're standing behind them i
see these fools pull out shanks and then
put it under their shirt like this
so this guy who's coming up to here to
me
is sitting here [ __ ] just talking
[ __ ] to my face right
meanwhile i'm just looking at those
dudes
yeah and then i'm like i i swear to god
this felt like a [ __ ] eternity yeah
it was maybe like a minute two minute
long and so i'm like what the [ __ ] like
i want to [ __ ]
like bank this dude right i'ma [ __ ] this
dude up but as soon as i punch this dude
my homies are gonna get stabbed yeah so
all these thoughts are running through
my head like
i'm like dude what what do i [ __ ] do
you know that gives me anxiety
no for sure so i'm thinking like oh [ __ ]
if they get stabbed their parents are
gonna [ __ ] have to you know go get
him at the hospital maybe they're gonna
die like what
because because i can't and then this
dude shoved me
right that's when i was i made a fist i
was
like oh you [ __ ] yeah and then my
other homie gets up out of his seat too
you know and and this is the only one
other homie who's like you know
who's kind of from that same background
yeah so he was down
right but then i still am in the
predicament i'm like what the [ __ ] do i
do here
yeah um and then the
only thing that [ __ ] say i couldn't i
couldn't take action i was like
paralyzed you know i had a fist i was
[ __ ] angry but then i'm like these
dudes are gonna [ __ ]
as soon as i punch him boom you know
like from the back that's it
yeah luckily thank [ __ ] god
cops showed up oh [ __ ] yeah that's the
only [ __ ] time i was
glad to see five only time in my [ __ ]
life
cops show up what's going on here and
i'm like
yeah i'm not an officer we're just you
know we're just all friends we're just
talking you know oh man i would have
snitched so
fast doc i would have been the biggest
snitch ever i'm like officer
those men have knives and they're trying
to assault me
that's i was just like oh you know
nothing's going on officer you know
we're just all friends we're just
talking you know we're just hanging out
um he's like you sure nothing's going on
here it's like nah it's cool dogs i
would have been blinking yes uh
obviously nothing's going on
i would have blinked
um and then so uh
after that happened those guys uh
left right they went back to the other
side
now little did they know there was
actually another table
um of group of guys that we knew and
they saw [ __ ] was going down too
and they had bottles on them so they
were starting to pour out their drinks
ready to [ __ ] hit the guys
who were standing behind my friends
they're behind those guys
and so it was just like this this just
[ __ ] cluster [ __ ] of a situation you
know
and all of it would have triggered with
me throwing that punch yeah and the guy
who came up to me
he never like punched me he just kept
pushing me yeah right
he wanted you to do yeah he wanted me to
yeah exactly he want he was instigating
and and like i was like thank [ __ ]
god
like that that situation kind of died
the way it died
and then i saw five minutes later those
dudes bounced yeah and i was like you
know what
we should get the [ __ ] out of here too
let's leave right
so we leave um after we leave from the
parking lot
maybe about 10 minutes later my homie
calls me he's like
hey you guys left for sure right and i
was like yeah why what's up
he's like i just came to get some gas
and those guys are at the gas station
oh she said i don't think they recognize
me but i hear them over talking they're
telling like they're calling their
friends to bring guns
and they're going to go back there god
damn
you know so like if if we stuck around
they probably would have lit us up
you know you should have just told the
cop they have
weapons on them officer and i am a good
christian boy dog i would have snitched
so fast dude you know i'm not about that
life i'm like [ __ ]
i would have been crying no but the
thing is though it's like you know
kind of it's like if if you have an
exchange of words
you got to be ready for it to you know
get to that level
right um i mean i've had friends get
stabbed from trying to stop a fight
yeah you know because [ __ ] pops off and
they're trying to get in the middle and
they get stabbed
you know so it's like you can't you
can't be around
that type of environment that type of
people even if you're like the most
peaceful dude
100 right and not expect something to
happen
and so like i think i told you the story
too like once i got into college
and then i would connect with some of
these you know friends or whatever
like one time we're hanging out in front
of a
you know dude's driveway just kicking it
cars driving by
everybody's acting a little bit weird
every time a car drives by like a little
bit
you know kind of fidgety i'm like yo man
the [ __ ] is going on is there something
i should know about like you guys are
acting weird every time a car is driving
by
like you know just let's just say get
ready to duck and roll
so i get the phone yeah i'm like not i'm
good on that man
i'm in college now you know i don't need
that [ __ ] i just [ __ ] left you know
but i think like that's the thing too
when uh
it's weird like when i hear these
stories like i you know i go back to
that moment where i'm just like this
young little goofy kid
and i see that dude get his [ __ ] air
force one spin on
and then [ __ ] a bunch of dudes stand
up and they're all strapped and i'm like
what the [ __ ] you know and i remember
too like in that moment
what it felt like i could kind of feel
it now i was scared
in those moments where you feel like
you're going to die feel like a
[ __ ] eternity yeah that i think that
altercation
had to be at most maybe 40 seconds right
40 seconds to a minute
relax right that [ __ ] felt like 20
minutes sure when you're
when when when [ __ ] is on the line man
that that thing is gonna feel like
forever you know that's why i was always
scared of guns
because just seeing that [ __ ] around you
makes you so scared
and i think like joan and i talked about
this too it doesn't really matter
because a girl was asking about you know
how to get out of gang affiliation i was
like i was never in a gang
but i do understand that just because
you think that
you could separate yourself from it
because you're not a gang member per se
and you want to just kick it with them
bullets don't [ __ ] discriminate man
if somebody comes up and they just start
spraying yeah you're gonna get shot
they're not gonna just oh okay and then
by the way and then shoot the person
next to you yeah i think that's like the
scary thing too i think people get
people get enticed by the the power and
the affiliation of being with somebody
who are or being with a group of people
that can enforce their will on somebody
else and it makes you feel empowered
yeah and it's usually from people who
kind of grew up either bullied or they
had a [ __ ] up uh
childhood or past and that's the stuff
that becomes the thing that you get
drunk off of yeah
you know and that's the thing it's like
thank god that that culture is not
popular anymore you know
i mean yeah you still see you still see
like people who are active in that type
of lifestyle and then
when i see it it's just fascinating to
me like we're in [ __ ] 2020 and uh
you still are about that life my god
you're a relic from the past but
you know i still can't believe you
didn't snitch i would have snitched so
bad dude
i had no pride in that [ __ ] when i see
somebody with a knife i'm like officer
just to let you know
no yeah [ __ ] right there he got
the knife to my friend neck [ __ ]
take him away [ __ ] but yeah i mean like
that was that was always the thing with
like the
the vietnamese gangsters is they always
roll deep man they were they were like
for sure
30 heads yeah man you guys don't [ __ ]
with people who who grew up in a
war-torn club exactly
exactly people like that like what they
grew up with and the stuff that they saw
is different from whatever you think
that you saw so
you grew up with people who i don't know
maybe your [ __ ] uncle was it was a
bang or whatever i'm talking about
people
escaped like government persecution
watching people die get shot
they don't give a [ __ ] yeah you know
that's why these like vietnamese
uh cambodian southeast asian gangs yeah
well they came over to the states and
people were trying to punk them and they
kind of
became this solid group of at the time
they were they became a gang
yeah right yo i just saw my my brother
get his arms exploded off when he
you know when he landed on a mine or i
saw somebody just try to saw my [ __ ]
limbs off and i think that this little
pistol scares me i'll find you and i'll
[ __ ] kill you right right right it's
frightening yeah even some of these like
old heads too like
uh some of like the the the older people
in our neighborhoods like yo we don't
[ __ ] with ages asians are [ __ ] crazy
because they know they know about like
the southeast asian gangs uh well i mean
that's the thing man is um
even in the la uh la area during the 90s
is like
you know asian gangs were holding their
own against
against you know like hispanic gangs and
black gangs or whatever
but problem was once they started
getting locked up now the prison system
is completely different yeah you don't
got
numbers there you don't got
representation so
there was a green light on asians when
they were getting locked up
and then once they got into prison it
was all bad game over man
yeah game [ __ ] over dude like yeah
honestly
getting killed would be a blessing you
know like just getting killed
and just having it end there dude our
friend our friend
told us one story where he uh really
nice dude but his his turning point
is his life was when he went to jail
if you met him now you would never think
that he was a piece of [ __ ] yeah
he's literally the straightest [ __ ]
arrow you ever met in your life but he
was telling me that when he went to jail
he had to be affiliated with
asian people if not he was just [ __ ]
so you don't really have much of a
choice you got to be with the people
that look like you no for sure it's
hybrid
for sure it is it is it's all right it's
for your protection exactly
and the thing is because there's no uh
representation for asians in a lot of
the prison systems here
you have when you make your claim you're
in the brothers and others group
yeah yeah so you're in with the the
black guys and and like others
yeah you know which is the minority
population he had to go with these uh
with a bunch of the the
the [ __ ] asian gangs and [ __ ] but you
know it was that whole [ __ ] hierarchy
punking situation
and they were in that whole time they
were grooming him to basically [ __ ]
fight
like like chickens with another with
another young dude that came into the
to the prison cell he was another asian
kid yeah and they were he was they were
grooming him training them making him do
push-ups work out so they could watch
them fight each other
and so the day before that they were set
up to fight he got let go he got
out he got bail so i think he told me it
was like a few months
and then the day before he's supposed to
throw down with this guy which he
doesn't want to fight
because he went to jail for i think it
was like robbing homes so he wasn't a
violent dude yeah yeah you know he just
liked money and i think he had
he had a a drug addiction so he was
feeling his drug addiction with the
money that he was getting from sleep
speaking of that man i saw so many
so many people just go down a dark dark
path with the [ __ ] drugs man
like one of my good homies too you know
that we grew up with
um at some point we kind of our paths
um split and um you know i i
wasn't seeing him on a regular basis at
all yeah and then
you know i i saw him i think when i was
like 15
you know and 15 or 16
around there there's just nobody home
when when i was trying to talk with him
and there's nobody home like it's just
lifeless behind his eyes i'm like dude
what the [ __ ] happened to you bro
like what are you on right now man i
think he was on like five different
things
you know he was dropping out of school
going to [ __ ] crack
houses and it's just like what happened
man like what the [ __ ] happened bro like
how the [ __ ] did you
end up like getting in this position in
this situation
um but that's the thing like some people
just have very
addictive personalities and when they
get hooked they get hooked yeah man
cocaine is a hell of a drug i saw a
video of this homeless person
that was on coke and he [ __ ] smoked
that pipe yeah and then he went to
another homeless dude
open up his butt cheeks and blew that
[ __ ] crack smoke in his ass he said
i was like yo cocaine is a [ __ ] hell
of a drug
this [ __ ] smoke coke it was like
crack coco i don't know what the [ __ ] it
was but he basically took a hit off this
pipe and he started blowing up this
dude's ass i was like
damn what the [ __ ] is going on with this
drug man this is a hell of a ride huh
that that's that's why drugs are scary
thing man
and it makes you do these crazy things
did you watch uh breaking bad
yeah of course man i've never wanted to
sell drugs so bad in my life man
i know it destroys communities but that
[ __ ] was man he was making so much money
he was
that greedy i mean that's the thing man
fast money's fast money
it comes fast and it goes fast you know
it never lasts
if i knew the formula to make that blue
magic
i would sell that [ __ ] the moment the
moment i hit
2 mil in cash yeah your boy's done i'm
off the radar
i will teach something that's what you
say that's what you say but but think
about it man
is it's not just about making the money
it's like the type of people you're
going to be dealing with
i'll groom somebody else as i'm doing
this
i'm going to groom some i'm going to
teach you everything hey guys this is
the new guy yeah he does it better than
me
you could have my cell number hit me up
whenever you want but
i've i've done my job i grew three or
four of these guys
you know what i've never ever seen
um somebody who who slangs right
makes it big time and not have it get
caught up with him at some point
never you know they never met david so
no i know one dude
i know one dude he did get caught up but
he was still able to bounce
uh bounce back from it and and and you
know
because he has a very entrepreneurial
spirit so yeah he put his you know
money to work in in other ways but aside
from him which is like
a huge exception
yeah man 9.9 out of 10 times man i don't
even like drugs though i would never
smoke my own supply dude i've
my biggest regret in life there are so
many things that people regret in their
lives my biggest regrets i never sold
drugs
i really wish i would have been this gay
i'm not even [ __ ] with you i legit
wish i would have sold [ __ ] weed in
high school
because i don't like it you know but i'm
a good business dude
i would have [ __ ] banked off that
[ __ ] man well that was the time to sell
it too
[ __ ] i mean like it was not easy to
really come across
you know and if you had somebody
actually everywhere my parents store i
was like i was just
i would have sold that [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] dude oh so that [ __ ] at my
parents store
that's your parents i put that [ __ ] in
some dax grease i'll put that [ __ ] in
the [ __ ]
uh a number two [ __ ] weave uh
ten inch i just put it inside the
[ __ ] weave and be like here you go
here your special order
it's like how much is it seventy dollars
you know why seventy
oh boy i would have [ __ ] done a great
job man
nah they said when i when i was slinging
it was just to smoke for free man
you know it's like that was that was the
motivation
you know i would have i would have grown
my own [ __ ]
it would have been nice you don't have
that time before sight when you're 13 14
years
old if i had a time machine that's what
i would have done oh yeah well if you
have a time machine
um but yeah man it was just that whole
era was
you know and the thing is i i would do
it all over again
you know i when i look at uh how
teenagers are growing up now
and how i grew up at that age i would
pick that that time period than this
korean time period
i i i don't really have a specific
reason for it
i just think right now it's just uh i
look at things
and just very soft and like too
sensitive you know
i'm like back then this is a little bit
more
uh rugged you know and
yeah sure there were a lot of crazy [ __ ]
going on um
and happening too sometimes uh
your your life might be threatened
makes you tougher you know it does make
you tough man i feel like
when you once you feel like you have
your life
in danger it kind of uh it's a very
unique experience it's it's weird how
like that slow down phase and it kind of
makes you rethink things a lot it's like
oh man this is uh this is not the thing
that i enjoy no for sure
but but you know we can't discount the
fact that we
are hugely fortunate and blessed to to
be able to look back on it
and and and think that in hindsight
right there are other people
who weren't as fortunate like who maybe
uh
weren't trying to do the things that
some of these people were doing but just
because by hanging out with them
or being affiliated with certain people
they got the shittier end of the stick
you know yeah man i mean when i look
back on it too i understand
why even though i you know i was never
in a gang or something like that why i
enjoyed it
being around something like like them
because of once again like i said it
before it was just the respect that you
would get from it
and specifically because i was such a
dweeby ass kid i was so geeky i had
these thick glasses
people would always target me you know
and it was always that kind of like i
don't know what it is like
that chip on your shoulder it's like i
was that one dude in the group where it
was like
he's gonna be the easy target but if you
piss him off he's gonna [ __ ] you up you
know what i mean because i was a big boy
yeah i've been decided since i was
[ __ ] uh in eighth grade yeah so i was
like five ten five eleven already in
eighth grade yeah but i was such a nice
dude
but i had a very bad temper so at that
point and obviously it starts to
equalize out when you're a little older
people start getting taller but when
you're [ __ ] 14 and you're 15 and
you're bigger than everybody else yeah
it's like
people of course they're gonna try to
punk the biggest nicest dude because
it's the easy target
but then that was the thing that always
used to bother me because i wouldn't
bother anybody else well
along with the hierarchy thing too it's
like it's really flexing because you see
like a big guy
and then it's usually the smaller guys
who are trying to do the punctuation
always right right because so so for
them it's like they think
i'm going to use you as a platformer
yeah yeah it was so [ __ ] annoying i
had to deal with that [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] yeah yeah and i just i
hated that [ __ ] i was like what the [ __ ]
no for sure for sure for sure um
there was a time when uh this i think he
was like a sophomore
when uh we were uh in eighth grade
so he's two years older so obviously
like he's already gone through puberty
so he's hit his growth spurt
he's a much bigger guy upperclassman
right
but he he did some [ __ ] to like one of
my homies and
basically like we we walked over to
where he was at
um and i think the dude
had like pulled a plastic knife or some
[ __ ] you know like something corny as
[ __ ]
right like he did something and he
pulled a plastic knife
what the [ __ ] yeah so so we went over to
him
yeah we made him get get on his knees
and apologize and beg for forgiveness in
front of all his friends
definitely nuts yeah to [ __ ] guys who
are 13 years old
14 years old you know but that was the
thing is that
it's like it's a different group you
know yeah it's like it doesn't matter we
don't respect the fact that you're older
yeah and that you're an upperclassman if
[ __ ] goes down what do you think is
gonna happen
yeah it really comes it really comes
down to that yeah and again so it's one
of those situations where
you have to make a call yeah is my pride
worth you know me getting my ass beat
or am i just going to suck it up and be
like i'm tell you some people
getting your ass beat does not feel good
it [ __ ]
sucks man especially like when uh some
of the older homies would they would get
into something and there's no real
questions
asked right and i think it's easier from
some people's perspective when they say
well you just didn't have to be in that
situation but
you didn't grow up like we did so you
don't understand what was at stake you
know for sure
the the how the protection felt good
yeah and it's like
at this time too you can't you can't
just take
and not give back yeah you can't take
that protection yeah and then when [ __ ]
goes down you don't do anything
there's a bigger consequence for that
[ __ ] yeah like you're the [ __ ] and then
they'll [ __ ]
you up so at this point i hated this
[ __ ] too it's like yo shit's going down
i'm like oh [ __ ]
yeah you know because i don't want to
fight yeah but i'm a big dude
so they expect certain things out of it
for sure the big guys always get the
most pressure
you know [ __ ] annoying yeah right so
whenever [ __ ] went down
dude this is one story where we're older
at this point
right um i'm not i i went to riverside i
got kicked out
and then uh i decided to go to community
college and
when i was by the time i was like 20
years old
i i just kind of stopped drinking heavy
so i was drinking heavy since i was like
[ __ ]
like 15. so i just stopped drinking um
and didn't really like it so much it was
just
even the first reason the main reason
why i drank in the first place was
because of social pressure for sure for
sure
the cool thing to do exactly right and
i'm a big guy i could drink pretty well
um but we were at this lady's house and
she used to grow like weed and [ __ ]
i heard she's like she's still in jail
because she uh obviously was giving out
drugs to minors
oh you know also when you say lady
you're talking about an older lady oh oh
oh oh okay like she
so in in sacramento when you go down
this road now there's like new housing
developments
but that whole road was just all farms
and [ __ ] well she had a plot of land and
a house
that she used to just let all of us kick
it at so we would throw parties in or
whatever what not right
and i she went to jail i think cause she
was growing like sativa and
she was just you know giving us weed and
[ __ ] i never smoked so i didn't do drugs
but you know she was just smoking people
loud people getting drunk everybody's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] is wrong with her
i don't know her kid she had a kid too
okay okay that makes sense i thought it
was just like this
random [ __ ] lady who's inviting
minors to her place
i never actually met her kid okay but i
only knew of that place
i'm not gonna say her name yeah yeah
yeah yeah out of respect because she was
so
so cool but we used to call her mama and
her name okay let's call her mama jack
yeah
mama jackie right and so uh there's one
time
because it's not just one time it's
happened multiple times but usually when
you guys see a party going down
if somebody wants to show up and they're
not [ __ ] invited that means they're
trying to start some [ __ ]
if you're not [ __ ] invited you're not
[ __ ] invited this isn't some kind of
open party where you kind of roll up
roll up to somebody's house unexpected
uninvited
and then you're like yo what's going on
yeah cause number one people are smoking
there's drinks they didn't contribute
they're not allowed to come through
you're not one of the homies right
so consistently this would be a huge
problem but the one time that it was
super big was when
i'm 22 at this point right i haven't
seen this lady in a very long time
and they were still throwing parties out
there that's crazy
all right cool whatever i'm not young
anymore but you know we went out there
and when we were kicking it i remember
this is this is
a buddy of mine and he's like yo some
dudes are trying to come into the party
and i'm like i already know what that
means man you know
i don't want to deal with this [ __ ] yeah
so i'm like okay i already know what
this means yeah and now mind you
i already felt like i was obligated to
do something because not too long ago
before that
he actually helped me out in a very bad
situation which i didn't want to be in
but then i called him up and he came
through so and we'll talk about the
story at another time but
he he helped me out so i still owed him
one
right which i didn't [ __ ] like yeah
and so i'm sitting there i'm just like
please please just
just leave yeah right but these dudes
rolled up to the house party and they
they wouldn't [ __ ] leave they decided
that they weren't going to leave and
they was like we're going to come
through anyways
[ __ ] bad idea yeah this dude has a
[ __ ] short temper and mind you
that part that house party everybody
knows each other right right
right some of them are affiliated some
of them aren't yeah but they're all
homies because we all grew up together
because most
at this point a majority of people
stopped doing stupid [ __ ] yeah they all
grew up yeah
so we're there and he goes hey man he
goes you know she's about to pop off i'm
like
[ __ ] and so literally you hear some [ __ ]
go down
he grabs a bat i grab a bat and it's
just on
and you're just swinging at that point
you don't know who the [ __ ] is hitting
anybody else
and i'm just cracking people and i'm
trying to do it in a way
where it's enough just to hurt them yeah
yeah not to kill them yeah
and at this point like it's just i just
remember
and it was dumb too because it's like a
house party full of like 30 people and
these guys roll up with like four guys
and obviously some of them check them
out see if they're strapped they weren't
even strapped what the [ __ ] did you
think it was gonna happen yeah
but then i guess they had a couple of
homies in the car waiting so it was four
guys in the front and they had like
three or four homies in the back i don't
remember i couldn't count it was super
late at night it was dark yeah but
all those [ __ ] got [ __ ] up
but just going through that situation
and thinking like
i have to do something because i owe
this guy something and it sucked right i
don't want to do that [ __ ]
i i just left uh uc riverside
uh maybe a couple years ago i was going
to community college and i was
transferred over i was trying to
transfer over to sac state
but because i made a choice to hang out
in that scenario that's what you get
this is what i get this is what i
deserve after that i'm like
for real no more of this [ __ ] like if
we're going over to like these big party
situations i don't know anybody
i'm just not going well okay first of
all a house party
still is never like a good idea yeah
like it's it's it's different from what
a house parties consider today
and then the house party we're talking
about from you know yeah yeah yeah that
time period so
it's just some [ __ ] always a recipe
for trouble
and disaster some [ __ ] always happens
bro man
i could talk to you i could i have so
many weird house party stories like bro
there's some of these girls too that
were [ __ ] hoes man i remember
i remember
does he listen to my podcast no okay
well just use an alias we'll use an
alias but this dude actually ended up
marrying this girl
right and he doesn't even [ __ ] know
when i when i when i met her my [ __ ]
heart sank into the bottom of my stomach
and i started sweating bullets
because he's an old friend of mine
talking about this girl
like she's the sweetest thing ever dude
when i saw her dude i was like
dog i specifically remember a house
party
where this [ __ ] to i'm sorry excuse
that word i'm saying she's a [ __ ]
because she
she was a trifling ass [ __ ] woman
it's not a phrase i use for all women
but she's
this girl was an [ __ ] yeah she wasn't
a great person right she was one of
those dude
girls that specifically hung around bad
[ __ ] like bad people
because she liked the way it made her
feel and she put a lot of people in
dangerous situations because of it
but one of those one of those you know
what girls i'm talking about right
her parents are [ __ ] uh one of her
her dad's a missionary yeah you know her
mom's uh
named you know so you know she didn't
grow up in a bad situation she's just
like being around bad people she's very
devious
very devious woman right she uh
i specifically remember a house party
where she grabbed three dudes and they
ran a train on her
upstairs and she would do this multiple
times right
and he don't even know [ __ ] about this
girl's past she's like yo man like she's
like
the sweetest girl i've ever met she's a
pastor this [ __ ] told me and i
[ __ ] you [ __ ] not and i just remember
that she was like
yo when i met her like she like you know
me like i like the [ __ ] but she wanted
to wait because you know she said like
she's only had like one other sexual
partner
bro oh i don't do that
i don't do that he was telling me all
this stuff about her right yeah
and when i i was like oh this woman's
pretty dope never met her yeah and i
the first time i ever met her was at the
wedding oh [ __ ] and then my
[ __ ] i i remember just having cold
sweats yeah
it's not like i was being grilled but
it's just i felt
terrible yeah yo this girl [ __ ] lied
to you well yeah so look
here's the thing you could transition
from a hoe to
you know for sure yeah but don't lie
that's what i'm saying don't do that
sold him on a [ __ ] journey don't
[ __ ] don't
don't make [ __ ] up you want to hear some
funny [ __ ] too when he introduces he
goes yo this is my wife
dog her face yeah i was like kind of
like cause she know
she knows who i am right because of the
older homies i was that geeky kid that
was always around
she knows who i am she avoided me
throughout that whole [ __ ]
and so after he was like yo this mom she
was oh hi and she kind of like had that
look and then she went to another table
i'm like oh so you know you've been
[ __ ] lying to this guy
because she was doing the whole
born-again christian thing
um which is cool we'll just don't yeah
that's fine but don't lie
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] lie you know i
mean like you don't have to go into
graphic details but don't [ __ ]
explicitly say oh i've only had one you
had a train wrench what's your
definition of one other part
wasn't that one time where three guys
were [ __ ] you in that room
those house parties were [ __ ] nuts
yeah oh my god
no for sure and so like again
referencing that time period like a lot
of you guys who are
like i would say in your younger 20s
mid-20s whatever
you probably have no [ __ ] clue what
we're talking about like this was
a completely different period and time
and and like
what people did for fun was was so
different from what it is now
and like for me i look at it now
and like i said i do feel like it's soft
but at the same time it's like hey
i'm not trying to advocate or promote
violence you know
like i'm i'm happy that that's not the
case anymore
but you know what like i was saying
earlier those dudes still exist
because uh i'll give you an example when
i was playing ball
so one of my little homies like he's
still kind of tied up
in that it's a complicated thing but
anyway he has hyungs and stuff right and
his homies
and they're they're serious about it and
so we we went out the ball and like
it's under the i've never met his hyungs
or his whatever i know i know the set
he's from though yeah
right because it's old set so i i mean i
know it's like not dudes to be [ __ ]
around with or like you know
but but like we're coming in a friendly
situation like oh this is
you know my big bro that i know and then
these are my hyungs and then we're just
coming to play ball together
but then like we started playing ball
and then like you know some of the older
young's like
like they started getting very
aggressive like like
shoving us and then like [ __ ] you
know like dogging us
like dude we're just trying to play some
basketball like no one's trying to start
[ __ ]
and then so i went over to my life i was
like hey man like what's up with your
young dude like why is he so aggressive
you know like he's
he's like trying to punk like my friends
and me like dude we're we're just trying
to play basketball
yeah ah you know he just got out so he
has some anger issues you know and i
was like why don't you tell me that [ __ ]
dude he's playing yard ball pretty much
and i'm like dude come on man nobody's
trying to like do
anything or like nobody's throwing it'd
be one thing if like we were trying to
get physically aggressive like throwing
a bow or something right
we're just playing ball you know so
people be getting mad at me when i play
ball because some i don't get aggressive
because i don't care i literally could
care [ __ ] yes
like when the opposite team yeah dope
shot i'm like yo that's just tight and
they're like the [ __ ] are you doing guy
i'll tell you what the [ __ ] i'm getting
some exercises yeah i'm like what are
you talking
about going for an nba trophy i'm just
saying that was a dope shot but people
are like yo get in the g
get your head in the game no but i know
i know because i get heated too like
even when it's friendly
you know how it's like run that [ __ ]
back yeah run that [ __ ] back you know
you get you get pretty heated uh
this knee anymore no no yeah i'm just
glad i'm allowed to touch a basketball
you know what the the funniest thing is
though is like uh
kind of going back to like the whole
thing about me
telling you when i got to like you know
predominantly asian area i was like so
foreign so before i got there
you know most of my homies that i was
hanging out with were mexican or black
right
and then uh one time we i remember this
uh i went with uh some of i went with a
mexican homie like his little brother
and maybe some was it just us three or
one other
person but we went to this area
where i later found out is like an asian
area i didn't know
it was just like a new thing that popped
up and so we went there to like
uh watch a movie hang out we went over
there and then we
were hanging out we were sitting down
and i think we were i was like
11 at that point and then we see
like a bunch of uh these 12 13 year olds
right who were like a year or two years
older than us but then clearly
you know they're they're they're like
the the beginning bangers right yeah
and they're mobbing like 15 20 heads and
then we see them
and like i again i hadn't seen something
like that before so i didn't really know
what it was right
and then they came over to our table and
then um
they try to tax us right oh [ __ ] yeah
and i didn't even know like i didn't
even i haven't even heard it hadn't even
heard of like taxing at that point
whatever
and it's like these dudes are coming
over and it's like
hey you know how much money you guys got
right and start off with that
and then it's like all right let me get
let me get like five dollars then you
know
the [ __ ] not though you [ __ ] fight
all the [ __ ] are you talking about right
and then now mind you the the mexican
homie that i'm with
his older brothers they're [ __ ] rough
dudes yeah
like you like those are dudes you not
want to [ __ ] around with yeah
and then so like i'm used to seeing
dudes
who are like essays yeah and then i
started seeing
these guys that's like my first
introduction to like these group of guys
and then um you know they were they were
basically trying to punk us but then
like my homie was like
the [ __ ] right he wasn't having it and
this guy was very short-tempered too uh
he used to get us into trouble all the
[ __ ]
all the [ __ ] time and then so he kind
of got
got into it with one of the dudes but
then nothing really happened right
and then out of the group i recognized
one of the guys like it's somebody that
uh i i knew
um i went up to him and i was like hey
like we know each other man like what
the [ __ ] you guys trying to do like
like we're just we're just hanging out
man right and then
you're just like ah you know it's cool
like forget it and then they started
doing petty [ __ ] they started throwing
ice at us
you know throwing ice at a table and
then um
like my homie was like hey [ __ ] that
[ __ ] i'ma call my brothers
oh [ __ ] like i don't think you gotta
call your brother's man
because i know that statement was
when he felt like all right we're gonna
take it to the next level yeah you know
and i'm like nah man you don't gotta
call your brothers man let's just get
out of here
yeah let's go somewhere else yeah let's
just let's just leave man like it's
it's cool um but it's so funny because
that was my first introduction to like
that type of
community i guess in that group and then
i got
there and then those are the people i
was interacting with and then hanging
out with eventually
you know funny yeah no they could have
died yeah dude
bro every time man every time this guy
would get into [ __ ] trouble he would
always do
something now he would he he could scrap
he was a good fighter
so i give him that much credit but he
would always pick a fight where it's too
much
it's too much and you're being rolled up
on it
it's so funny when those kind of
situations happen like you just brought
this memory
one time when i was i was walking home
and so in uh sacramento there's a
in i think it's north highlands there's
an area where there's just a bunch of
like north eno's right
so if you guys know what like northeast
are like it's
ceremonials are like this outsiders
south side like mexican mexican right
now daniel's like mexican-american yeah
you know so
they have their they're actually rival
right rival gangs yeah
so growing up there was this one mexican
kid that i grew up with around the block
that
uh he ended up being a northeno right
but we were friends
really nice kid you know but obviously
when your family is affiliated you just
get kind of drawn into that for sure for
sure
i'm a freshman in high school at this
point right i don't know where he lives
but he actually moved from like the
i think he moved to north highlands
that's where his his uh other relatives
were
but he grew up on my same street and my
street's not bad it's like you know
decent street yeah uh
i was walking home one day super late at
night from my friend's house and he
lived
right over there these dudes are rolling
up in a [ __ ] car he's like yo what's
up
what's up kid you know saying a bunch of
[ __ ] and i looked up i was like oh [ __ ]
this was about the [ __ ]
they're banging on me right now right i
look up he goes
david yeah so bro oh
yeah his name was like aurelio right i
was like what's up bro he was like yeah
he's like oh man it's like just walking
at home at night
you [ __ ] nuts bro my
[ __ ] god man he was just super nice
to me and it's so funny how different we
were because he was a little dweeby kid
just like me
but you know he's changed when your
family i mean we didn't i didn't know
what that [ __ ] was
but that was super nice to me and he
dropped me off at my house
that she scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] it was
him it was him and two other dudes and
they [ __ ]
came out the [ __ ] window like what's
up yeah hey
that's the thing man it's like you know
those guys like some of them
are for reals man like they're family
you know and like you said if you're if
you're
kind of growing up in that environment
it's just it's just natural to
to kind of be a part of that there's
those moments too i'm like man
i think god gots my back dude thank
[ __ ] god but those moments are so
scary because
it's i just remember just walking and
when they're trying to say what's up i'm
i'm ignoring them because i don't i
don't know what to do because i'm so
scared
you know i'm i'm like 14 15 at the time
and i know what that means yeah you know
so i'm like yeah [ __ ] like i'm only
maybe a couple of blocks away from my
house i'm just like [ __ ]
and i'm just kind of walking just
looking down not saying anything not
saying anything
and then when they get super close and
they get loud you got to look up yeah
and thank god he knows who the [ __ ] i am
right i'm like this was trying to
[ __ ] jack me yeah
that's that's what i'm saying things
like that you know i'm glad that
uh kids that age don't have to really go
through that stuff for the most part i
mean
in certain neighborhoods that should
still exist you got it yeah you got to
obviously
um be a little bit more mindful of your
environment and like you know with the
colors you wear and you know
who you're around right but for the most
part it's not as popularized and
glamorized as it was
like when we were growing up so that's a
good thing but i just wish
you know kids weren't so [ __ ] soft
man going through all these like this
stuff down memory lane and uh
i mean these weren't great experience
for me you know it's not like i i
i think i was just very fortunate and uh
sometimes like when you
all this all this like relationship that
you made when you were younger just kind
of
panned out to help me out later on yeah
which yeah no but it's a process
so the reason why i say i would do it
all over again is not because
like i i'm trying to necessarily say
that oh i i enjoyed
partaking in that or what because it
ultimately shaped
me for who i am now you know those those
were all learning experiences and the
important thing is
that i learned from it if i didn't learn
from it and i just kind of stayed in the
same space
that's a different story you know um but
and here's the way when we tell these
stories too some of these kids they it's
almost hard for them to believe they're
like oh how
it's like how do you have so many
stories it's like dog this was like an
everyday [ __ ] occurrence
like i don't think you understand i
can't even remember
probably 80 of the stories now because
of how commonplace it was
right right only in conversation yeah
does some of this stuff start to spark
up again
yeah i don't know whether it's because i
repressed it or i buried it but i didn't
like those situations it was very
[ __ ] uncomfortable
because because life doesn't need to be
like that man
that's not it's like for for those of
you out there who don't know what it's
like growing up
i mean there's still people right now
who grew up in like projects in like
very hood-ass
areas they still deal with this [ __ ]
yeah and but
being a kid like that where i'm just
like this geeky nice kid
having to to try to navigate my life to
that was very [ __ ] hard man
because i wasn't allowed just to be
myself that's why once again i had to
find other people that i felt very safe
with
and if somebody [ __ ] with me these older
people my hyungs would come in and they
would help me out
so it was like okay like i can't even be
myself i couldn't
i couldn't like you guys are so lucky
watching anime and
all this [ __ ] is cool i had to keep that
[ __ ] hidden
you know you had to be low-key you had
to be low-key about it and i would kind
of test the waters to see if somebody
else likes that [ __ ] i'm like
yeah you know that [ __ ] [ __ ] you talking
about right now dave i'd be like you
know that [ __ ] whack-ass dragon ball
[ __ ] and then
he's like i kind of like that like yo me
too [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you know so i would have to like test
these waters i didn't join choir for the
longest time because i didn't want to be
judged by
kind of the homies outside of my high
school yeah because if they found out
that i was in
choir [ __ ] and they would just you know
make fun of me and they would use the f
word on me
dude that's the thing is that there was
a certain appearance
like you would have to keep because like
you said you know
like people would check you for it yeah
man and thank god like around like
sophomore junior and senior year of high
school
i just i just stopped caring like i was
like what's going to happen these
i got to do what i want to do you know
and at the end of the day
what am i asking protection from like
technically i don't need to be walking
outside late at night
and the reason why i was walking at home
late at night is because i was kicking
in with them so if i wasn't kicking with
them in the first place i would have got
rolled up on
yeah so you know you just kind of start
to realize like how stupid this [ __ ] is
like i'm asking for protection because
of situations that i put myself in
that's dumb that's [ __ ] done yeah it
doesn't make any sense yeah you know
what i mean yeah
i was like i need protection from guys
because the guys i'm hanging out with
got [ __ ] with those guys exactly that's
terrible
yeah well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast i
hope you enjoyed that there's
a thousand million more stories yeah
there's i mean honestly it's it's
endless
endless i mean there's certain things
that i don't even really want to get
into
honestly yeah because uh it might like
identify certain people and i
don't want to do that like i i've
already i've already proven i ain't no
[ __ ] snitch like somebody yeah
i snitched somebody out real quick dude
like we're looking for this person that
was murdered
uh 20 years ago i'm like let me tell you
something i know their address and
exactly where they live
they work at intel right now but you
know what
snitching stitches get stitches that's
that's why
that's not that's like not this not this
niche
all right this dish quick dude i'm out
of there dog you don't even know with
that knee you're gonna either you're
gonna have that type of reflex i buy an
electric bicycle
oh my god i'm out well
where can they find you uh instagram ed2
edtwo secret society scrt society.com
same thing for the handle for secret
society on instagram and twitter
that's about it yeah well we'll see you
guys next time every thursdays and
sundays remember to
to download the the podcast see us on
itunes spotify and every single
audio platform out there every thursday
and sundays you will see a new episode
and we'll see you all next time oh and
real quick guys i
i'm really curious like from your guys's
uh what your life is
what your thoughts are on this the type
of topic we're talking about i'm really
curious
about what your thoughts are so if
whatever your thoughts are write it in
the comments if you guys have questions
also ask in the comments i'm just
curious you know i want to know what
these kids think about that type of [ __ ]
so bet you they love it they're just
like oh that's so cool and it's not cool
it was not a great time for me
it was not a great time for me it's just
story time that's all guys you know
maybe a great time for him he was taxing
people [ __ ]
peace